sarr en sept années 90 où la france se
prépare à célébrer le centième
anniversaire de la naissance du général
de gaulle
que reste-t-il du mouvement et qui porte
sinon son nom du moins son héritage
les quatre des quatre protagonistes qui
se sont affrontés avant-hier aux assises
du rpr monsieur le ministre vous êtes le
seul à avoir vécu cette époque
d'où le gaullisme tire sa légitimité et
sa grandeur c'est à dire l'époque de la
résistance depuis dimanche vous est
l'incontestable numéro deux du rpr vous
êtes vous êtes en tout cas le principal
interlocuteur de monsieur jacques chirac
et après l'avoir vu tout à l'heure à 20h
dans le journal d'hervé claude et bien
on a envie de vous entendre ce soir
alors le monde le monde a beaucoup
changé en cours de l'année 1989
monsieur pasqua et pourtant votre parti
le rpr est resté très silencieux pendant
que cette année 89 il n'a rien dit ou
presque
lorsque le mur de berlin s'est effondré
il n'a rien dit non plus lorsque
monsieur de l'or a dit qu'il faudrait
que les 12 pays du marché commun
constitue une seule et même nation
en d'autres temps vous le savez mieux
que moi le fondateur de la vème
république aurait fait entendre sa voix
il aurait donné son avis sur le nouvelle
équipe du monde ses héritiers ne l'ont
pas fait alors vous nous expliquerez ce
soir pourquoi ce silence
quelle est votre analyse de la crise que
traverse actuellement le rpr qui je le
précise pour la première fois de son
histoire est maintenant partagée entre
une majorité et une minorité
alors de quelle promesse le gaullisme
est il porteur pour les jeunes comment
voyez vous l'avenir de la france comment
voyez vous l'avenir de l'europe
est ce que l'allemagne réunifiée vous
fait peur
et bien c'est parti maintenant pour une
heure avec tout de suite une première
question des téléspectateurs s&p
geneviève moll
bonsoir monsieur pasqua première
question qui nous vient d'un cadre de
paris ne vous sentez vous pas pour
partie responsables du blanchiment de
l'argent de la drogue
alors que vous avez conforter l'assise
financière des casinos en 88 avec les
machines à sous
les casinos le casino étant souvent
milieu de blanchiment c'est direct
brutale
les machines à sous ça marchait avec des
pièces et si on voulait blanchir
l'argent de la drogue avec des pièces ça
prendrait vraiment beaucoup de temps et
de patience
bien alors alain duhamel pour un quart
d'heure
bonsoir monsieur pasqua re bonsoir
monsieur duhamel alors vous avez
remarqué comme nous tous que pendant la
campagne électorale interne du rpr et
encore dimanche au bourget jacques
chirac avait dit qu'il n'y aurait ni
vainqueur ni vaincu à l'issue du vote au
rpr est ce que vous trouvez qu'il n'y a
ni vainqueur ni vaincu
je crois que il n'y a pas de raison de
considérer qu'il y ait des vainqueurs ou
des vaincus
nous appartenons au même mouvement nous
militons pour les mêmes idées il ya eu
un affrontement vif un débat auxquel
naturellement nous compagnons sont pas
tellement habitués mais jacques chirac
avait lui même fixé la barre qu'il
considérait comme nécessaire d'un
soutien aux deux tiers il a eu ses deux
tiers dont il est parrain que et vous
quant à nous on est crédité de 14% l'an
a fait un peu plus du double je crois
qu'au nez ce soir 32 puisqu'il ya eu un
recomptage
donc nous sommes relativement satisfaits
de personne ne souhaitait le départ de
jacques chirac
mais je pense que naturellement le débat
était un peu biaisé à partir du moment
où il s'était lui-même engagé où il
avait mis son poids dans la balance
il n'en reste pas moins que le sentiment
que nous avions eu au cours de notre
tour de france avec philippe seguin à
savoir d'une grande volonté de
changements et de transformations cette
volonté elle s'est manifestée et on vous
pensez que ce soir
après le temps de la réflexion jacques
chirac alain juppé philippe seguin et
vous vous pouvez tous les quatre aussi
content peut-être le niveau 2 du
contentement est il différent selon que
vous voulez pas eu l'apprécié comme ça
en 2000 nous nous sommes content très
content de vous contestez pas le chiffre
qui vous donnent des tombes par le
chiffre non bon est ce que vous êtes des
gens pas nous qui avons demandé à ce
qu'on raconte
et est ce que vous avancez dans
seulement demandé à ce qu'on recompte le
les bulletins du conseil national oui
parce que là nous n'avons que 14 élus
alors 14 ça fait juste 14%
ça correspondait aux sondages tels
qu'ils avaient été indiqué qu'une
coïncidence mais la vie est faite de
coïncidence et est ce que est ce que
vous considérez que maintenant le
fonctionnement du rpr tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui c'est devenu un
fonctionnement aussi démocratique que
vous le souhaitez je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup à faire sur le plan des
structures sur le plan du comportement
et aussi sur le plan des idées parce que
les structures c'est une chose
un parti c'est bien mais pourquoi faire
mon avenir solide et je crois que sur le
plan des structures il ya beaucoup à
faire nous en avons d'ailleurs parlé
longuement ce matin pensez bien que
puisque nous sommes restés une heure et
demi ensemble avec jacques chirac alain
juppé philippe seguin et moi nous avons
parlé de l'essentiel et l'essentiel
c'est notamment cela que vous lui avez
fait des propositions nous exprimer des
demandes nous n'avons fait aucune bande
nous sommes demandeurs de rien nous
avons fait des remarques et nous avons
fait des suggestions noms et leurs
suggestions
si on n'est pas en trop nos suggestions
elles sont relativement simple n'est-ce
pas mais ça ne concerne pas que le rpr
nous allons parler du rpr puisque vers
perth et notre mouvement mais ça
concerne tout le monde
le sentiment que nous avons c'est plus
qu'un sentiment en tous les cas le
sentiment qu'ont les français c'est que
les partis politiques vivent pour
eux-mêmes et recroquevillés sur eux
mêmes et le nôtre aussi
donc il faut l'ouvrir le nôtre
naturellement ce look rock puisque plus
que les autres alors il faut l'ouvrir et
il faut débattre avec les français n'ont
plus seulement entre soi c'est très bien
de faire des combats
des réunions des colloques des
conciliabules et tout ce qu'on voudra
mais ça n'intéresse personne
par contre ce qu'il faut c'est que les
hommes politiques
enfin d'abord il devrait se rendre
compte du déphasage que vous signalez
vous même temps qu aux éditoriaux alors
je vais pas vous répondre non non on est
d'accord
- d'accord bien le déphasage entre la
classe politique on est d'accord mais
peu de gens tirent les conséquences et
les conclusions alors nous nous pensions
que le moment est venu
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que nous
souhaitions avec philippe seguin et ceux
qui nous ont soutenus nous souhaitions
que notre mouvement soit le premier à en
tenir compte et à se transformer alors
pour ouvrir les fenêtres les portes
qu'est ce qu'on fait en deux mots bien
pour ouvrir les fenêtres et les portes
il faut débattre lorsqu'un problème se
pose il faut en parler non seulement
entre soi mais ils font parler avec les
français pour ça il faut sortir de chez
soi il faut aller à la rencontre des
français où il se trouve et il faut leur
demander leurs sentiments parce que les
français
individuellement sont déjà un peu
fantasque mais collectivement ils font
preuve d'un très grand bond de sens
alors il ya deux thèmes que je veux dire
monsieur duhamel je crois que je vois il
ya il ya deux thème sur lequel je
voudrais qu'on insiste un petit peu
ensemble
le premier c'est sur l'appréciation que
vous portez maintenant sur l'avenir et
les capacités de jacques chirac et
l'autre sur l'union de l'opposition ont
d'abord j'aimerais savoir vous l'avez
encore vu ce matin avec philippe seguin
est-ce qu'il ya maintenant après ce qui
vient de se passer pendant six semaines
est-ce quelque chose de déchirer entre
jacques chirac et vous pas non non
affectivement non plus quand il a dit
c'était mon ami vous rappelez il y avait
dix à patrick poivre d'arvor s'est
récemment j'ai dû autre chose c'était de
la campagne sa méthode ça sur le compte
d'un peu de l'énervement réciproque est
ce que vous considérez que il reste dur
et lui-même ce soir sur une antenne je
crois que c'était là sûrement ça oui
tout ce qui se fait de bien et c'est
tout naturellement et je crois qu'il l'a
dit lui-même non les problèmes ce ne
sont pas des problèmes
personnel ce sont deux ce sont les
problèmes qui se sont posés sont
directement liés à l'analyse que nous
avons faite de la situation politique et
aux conséquences que nous allons tirer
alors ça et cette analyse et ses
conséquences n'étaient pas les mêmes
ça on va y venir quand on va parler de
l'union mais je voudrais en ce qui le
concerne jacques chirac est ce que vous
charles pasqua qui le connaissaient bien
mieux que la plupart des autres
dirigeants
est-ce que vous avez l'ombre d'un doute
sur ses capacités de présidentiable donc
deux présidents potentiels
je crois que j'ai pu juger peut-être
plus que d'autres de ses qualités
d'homme d'état
elles sont réelles pour être président
de la république que je crois que c'est
comme pour être un grand homme il faut
la rencontre de circonstances
exceptionnelles et d'un grand caractère
nous verrons bien l'avenir nous le dira
et est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un d'autre au
sein du rpr qui puisse avoir
légitimement la même ambition
non non et en dehors du rpr par exemple
moi valéry giscard d'estaing oui
certainement certainement il a été
président de la république ça vous a pas
échappé non ça m'a pas échappé
ça m'avait jamais mais si j'aime je veux
dire par là si je me dis enfin j'ai donc
si j'ai bonne mémoire me corrigerez si
je me trompe mais si j'ai bonne mémoire
il me semble me rappeler qu'ils ne vous
donnerai pas absolument satisfaction à
l'époque c'était pas votre tasse de thé
oui mais ça nous sommes en démocratie
ça ne m'a jamais empêchée de considérer
que monsieur giscard d'estaing cet ol-om
de qualité
je n'étais pas toujours d'accord avec ce
qu'il faisait ça c'est un autre problème
mais qu'ils aient les capacités et les
qualités et quillan et d'autre part en
vie ça ça me semble évident bon le rat
comme monsieur giscard d'estaing y en a
d'autres les l'histoire du mais vous en
voyez d'autres dont vous diriez comme
vous le dites à propos de giscard il en
a les capacités
oui par exemple bon bah et en dehors
d'eux seuls ces deux là qui ont déjà été
soit candidat soit communément de
jacques chirac de raymond barre de
valéry giscard d'estaing pour le moment
à l'heure actuelle au mans
parlons je ne vois personne d'autre mais
les élections présidentielles ont lieu
dans cinq ans ça change pas beaucoup
alors oui mais c'est comme ça pour
préparer quelqu'un il faut du temps
c'est pas en étant ministre ou
secrétaire d'état une fois et pas
longtemps il faut plus de temps que ça
bien vous pensez à quelqu'un non c'est
une réflexion que vous aviez exprimé et
des semaines passées à plusieurs
reprises des réserves sur l'idée de
jacques chirac d'un contre gouvernement
est ce que après avoir vu ce matin avoir
discuté
vous continuez à être sceptique sur
l'utilité d'un contre gouvernement
tout ce qui peut concourir à renforcer
l'union de l'opposition et par
conséquent sa crédibilité est bon est ce
que ça concourt je crois qu'avant de se
lancer dans cette démarche il vaudrait
mieux s'assurer que les autres peuvent
l'accepter
faute de quoi on risque d'obtenir le
résultat contraire à celui que l'on a
recherché mais derrière cette idée se
profile un vrai problème si on ceci on
est d'ores et déjà en train de se mettre
dans la perspective d'une nouvelle
cohabitation
je crois qu'on commet une erreur
monumentale vous vous seriez contre une
nouvelle cohabitation c'est à dire que
si l'opposition gagne les législatives
dans trois ans vous pensez qu'elle ne
doit pas cohabiter comme elle l'a fait
la dernière fois ça c'est certain
c'est certain ah oui etc et pourquoi est
ce que cette fois-ci vous pensez ça et
que la fois d'avant vous pensiez
autrement parce qu on a déjà donné
parce que vous avez perdu non parce
qu'on a fait une expérience nous sommes
entrés dans la co habiter dans le
système de cohabitation s'était
d'ailleurs manuel connu en mai nous
sommes entrés dans ce système de
cohabitation avec notre bonne foi et je
vais vous faire sourire monsieur duhamel
je dirais même avec notre kamber et nous
avons eu nous avions en face de nous
quelqu'un qui lui s'est comporté tout à
fait différemment et qui n'a pas
respecté les règles du jeu nous avons
commis à mon avis deux erreurs la
première lorsque françois mitterrand 14
juillet 86 a refusé de signer les
ordonnances nous aurions dû partir vous
l'aviez proposé à jacques chirac edouard
balladur et moi à
on fait une démarche auprès de jacques
chirac pour lui dire il nous semble
qu'il faudrait partir il arrivé jacques
chirac était très tenté de le faire mais
il nous a dit je suis déjà parti une
fois je peux pas avoir l'air de devenir
un spécialiste ce genre de choses nous
sommes donc restés
la seconde erreur que nous avons commise
on en a sûrement commis des autres et la
seconde erreur que nous avons commise a
été d'accepter qu'au moment des
élections présidentielles une partie du
gouvernement combatte son chef ça
c'était inadmissible ça nous a coûté
très cher alors ça veut dire que la
prochaine fois si vous gagnez des
prochaines élections législatives
vous faites la grève du pouvoir à ce
moment là ça veut dire que de toute
façon nous sommes pour l'alternance
total et non pas partiel faute de quoi
ce sera deux ans pour nous et cinq ans à
nouveau pour les socialistes c'est un
système qui n'est pas équilibré dans le
figaro de demain il ya une interview de
françois léotard présidents des partis
républicains qui était ministre de
jacques chirac en même temps que vous et
qui revient à nouveau très clairement
est très fermement sur l'idée d'une
formation commune à l'ensemble de
l'opposition
et il avance notamment un argument vous
allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
edit à partir du moment où on veut un
candidat unique pour l'élection
présidentielle c'est normal qu'ils aient
une formation commune avec à l'intérieur
des courants un courant gaulliste coran
libérales etc
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est une
démarche intéressante mais encore je dis
que c'est une démarche intéressante joie
avec satisfaction et plaisir que
monsieur liotard est d'accord avec
monsieur giscard d'estaing pour une fois
parce que lorsque je m'étais entretenu
du projet de primaires pour la sélection
d'un candidat unique de l'opposition dès
le premier tour des présidentielles
monsieur giscard d'estaing avait d'abord
donné son accord il m'a dit c'est une
très bonne idée
puis lorsque nous étions en revue un
jour au comité
je sais plus comment l'appel supérieur
de l'opposition enfin bref il m'avait
dit c'est une bonne idée mais auparavant
il faut faire un parti unique
oui c'est ce que dit françois léotard
demain vous et monsieur on a un parti
unique c'est plus la peine de faire des
primaires problème sera réglé
pourquoi on paie parce que dans un parti
uni en douce sans personnalité
chacune comprend bien que si l'on se
décide à faire aujourd'hui un parti
unique où on ferait un parti unique avec
direction collégiale
ça ne marcherait probablement pas ou en
forêt un parti unique avec quelqu'un qui
le dirait je rêve mais alors est ce
quelqu'un qui le dirigera il faudrait
vraiment qu'il est une dose un esprit de
sacrifice extraordinaire pour ne pas
imaginer qu'il pourrait être candidat
lui même
or en réalité la remarque de françois
léotard me surprend parce que le parti
de l'union existe actuellement il est
très largement majoritaire dans le pays
à la base c'était liste les électeurs
les électeurs sont pour l'union est ce
que les électeurs justement qui sont
pour l'union ne vont pas se sentir
frustré si même à propos de l'union
il yad'un côté charles pasqua et jacques
chirac
du même avis je relève lee dans notre ça
a l'air de vous étonner d'un autre côté
françois léotard et valéry giscard
d'estaing également du même avis mais
pas du même que vous non le seul moyen
est ce pas le régler le problème il faut
pas se faire d'illusions à l'heure
actuelle l'avenir de l'opposition est
hypothéquée par les ambitions
présidentielles
il est clair que jacques chirac
souhaitons être candidat il a quand même
ses deux millions et demi deux mois la
dernière fois sur son nom ce qu'il a
fallu choisir entre lui et mitterrand
c'est normal valéry giscard d'estaing
bien envie d'y revenir
il a fait encore plus de 12 millions oui
alors donc ça voilà ça me fait déjà 2
raymond barre nous annoncer son réveil
il ya quelques temps je ne doute pas que
le moment venu souhaitera y aller
françois léotard souhaite mettre ses
qualités et notamment sa jeunesse ce qui
est un état transitoire et fugitif au
service de la nation française il faut
donc qu'ils se dépêchent les centristes
voudront certainement présenter soit
méhaignerie soit une autre nous voilà
déjà 5
je crois savoir qu'il ya le maire d'une
grande ville
qu'ils se sentent voulait faire son nom
aux rues se dit que c'était la vie dorée
s'arrêtera plus clair à tous c'est un
ami c'est michel noir n'est pas un
problème mais y en a peut-être d'autres
alors nous allons arriver facilement 8
au 10 candidats
comment voulez vous qu'on arrive à une
solution quelconque dès que lundi une
chose j'allais dire dès que l'on dit
blanc l'autre dit noir sur quelques jeux
de mots faciles
ouais merci merci merci alain duhamel
on continuera une fois voilà on retourne
asvp une autre question geneviève
viennent alors mais c'est parce qu
est-ce que votre désaccord avec jacques
chirac n'est pas un moyen de récupérer
l'électorat l'électorat lepéniste
le désaccord que nous avons eues avec
jacques chirac n'est pas un moyen de
récupérer l'électorat lepéniste
mais il procède d'une analyse que nous
avons fait philippe seguin moi même et
d'autres et qui est la suivante la
stratégie actuellement suivi par
l'opposition qui consiste à rechercher
l'union des états majors nous paraît
déboucher à terme sur l'échec aux
élections
sauf à vouloir s'entendre avec le front
national parce que si on est à 35 37%
des voix dans le cadre d'un scrutin
majoritaire
si on ne s'entend pas avec le front
national on ne peut pas l'emporter alors
à partir du moment où l'on dit qu'on ne
veut pas s'entendre avec le front
national ce qui est dit par les uns et
par les autres
la démarche actuelle nous paraît
complètement aberrant nous notre
démarche est d'une autre nature
et nous disons qu'il faut sortir du
système actuel il faut s'adresser aux
français leur proposer notre projet pour
la société française
un autre avenir pour la france en tous
les cas indiqué celui que nous voulons
et dans les conditions actuelles qui
sont caractérisées par le désarroi d'une
partie de l'électorat de gauche et
d'autre part par l'hybridation d'une
partie de l'électorat de droite
si nous créons un nouveau rassemblement
est ce que nous en
voulu dire alors nous pouvons récupérer
une grande partie des électeurs de
droite une partie importante aussi sur
notre gauche est ainsi constitué non pas
une grande partie du centre d'un grand
parti qui occupera cette partie centrale
et autour duquel se reconstituera la
majorité nouvelle
on va continuer sur cette question de
votre stratégie avec jean marie
colombani jean marie colombani pour un
quart d'heure le corps et on va parler
français pour être compris du plus grand
nombre
hélas restons sur les problèmes de
l'union parce que vous avez dit à peu de
choses près un petit peu ce que disait
françois léotard tout à l'heure parce
que alain duhamel nous rapportait dans
votre discours de dimanche aux assises
vous avez dit il faut donc faire des
primaires pour désigner un candidat
unique de l'opposition à l'élection
présidentielle et à ce moment-là
disiez-vous la grande formation commune
à vocation majoritaire existera ipso
facto
donc on a l'impression que vous aussi au
fond vous voulez aller vers cette grande
formation et que sans le dire vous êtes
aussi pour une certaine forme à terme de
fusion n'est pas du tout non monsieur
colombani
vous êtes trop fin observateur de la vie
politique française et
et analystes pour ne pas savoir qu'en
définitive nous ne reprendrons pas le
pouvoir
s'il n'existe pas un parti qui rassemble
un parti au mouvement politique qui
rassemble dès le premier tour
plus de 30 % du corps électoral au
lendemain des élections présidentielles
qu'il s'agisse de philippe seguin des
rénovateurs de leur côté ou deux mois et
d'autre d'une autre nous avons fait la
même analyse
mais nous avons procédé à une approche
différente en ce qui concerne les
rénovateurs j'ai été conduit à mon poser
à leur démarche
lorsque il m'a semblé qu'en réalité elle
était inspirée par les centristes et que
leur ambition c'était d'arriver à
l'éclatement du rpr et d'ailleurs j'ai
constaté que le jour où les choses sont
apparues clairement un philippe seguin
notamment au moment des élections
européennes lorsqu'il s'est agi ce qu'on
a proposé aux rénovateurs au nôtre ceux
qui sont de notre groupe de notre
mouvement de constituer une liste aux
élections européennes qui aurait été une
liste dissidente et de division philippe
seguin ya mis un terme en ce qui me
concerne le parti des 30 % ça doit être
le rassemblement new look que vous
proposez le parti des 30 % il pouvait
s'obtenir de trois façons premièrement
par l'éclatement du rpr au profit de
l'udf
deuxièmement par l'éclatement de l'udf
au profit du rpf probablement plus
facile à réaliser mais qui n'est pas
souhaitable non plus troisièmement en
bousculant un peu le l'échiquier
politique actuelle et notre sentiment
nous c'est qu'à l'heure actuelle on peut
parfaitement obtenir par la création de
ce nouveau rassemblement et d'une
nouvelle dynamique
cette formation à vocation majoritaire
avec des alliés est ce qui est tout à
fait normal c'est la condition pour
laquelle selon vous votre champion sera
désigné à l'occasion des primaires parce
que je n'imagine pas que vous alliez à
des primaires dans l'opposition pour
faire désigner monsieur giscard
d'estaing à monsieur colombani
il est bien évident qu'à partir du
moment où l'on pose des règles
on les accepte n'est ce pas moi j'ignore
complètement j'ai proposé ce système il
vous a pas échappé que je l' ai proposé
avec monsieur gérard longuet qui n'est
pas allée chiraquie à une conditionnelle
avec monsieur philippe mestres qu'il
n'est pas elle non plus avec alain
peyrefitte qui était repères c'est
indiscutable avec un certain nombre de
constitutionnalistes nous avons
réfléchir avant de proposer un système
je vous rappelle que le système que nous
avons proposés se soumet à l'arbitrage
des électeurs et il est différent
d'ailleurs de celui que propose jacques
chirac jacques chirac propose que ce
soit devant les élus en gros que ce
système se déroule puisqu'ils proposent
un rassemblement des élus dans ce but et
vous honorez plutôt les militants ou au
moins les électeurs n'ont pas les vivres
les électeurs d'encourager l'audit
absolument pas alors là je dois dire
tout de suite que je suis
s'il s'agit de faire une convention des
élus nationaux et locaux pour débattre
avec du système des primaires pourquoi
pas et il est bien évident que les élus
locaux ont leur rôle à jouer d'ailleurs
dans le système que nous avons proposés
ils ont ce rôle à jouer mais s'il s'agit
de faire désigner le candidat par les
élus locaux et nationaux la réponse est
non je crois que c'est un mauvais
système
nous nous sommes pour en quelque sorte
l'appel au peuple
nous sommes pour la démocratie directe
alors il faut en tirer les conséquences
c'est au peuple de se prononcer seul un
petit peu de la mecanic vallée valoir
mission on y va on y va justement parce
que les ambitions c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus facile justement parce que le
relance dans tous les discours on entend
au fond vous avez repris un petit peu à
l'égard de jacques chirac le discours
que laurent fabius avait tenus à l'égard
de michel rocard l'un disait il a pas de
grands desseins et puis vous vous disiez
il manque un message il manquait qu
est-ce que ce n'est pas une façon un peu
facile au fond de mobiliser parce que en
effet dans une période de calme
intérieur de gestion c'est toujours
facile de dire oui mais il manque une
grande ambition qu'est ce que c'est
cette grande ambition nous d'abord nous
avons souffert
indiscutablement et moi le premier mais
je n'ai pas été le seul
nous avons souffert de
l'absence de jacques chirac et du fait
que pendant un an et demi pratiquement
il sait qu alors au lendemain des
élections présidentielles était normal
qu'ils prennent du recul tout le monde
l'a compris encore pendant quelques mois
peut-être mais ensuite et comme le
rappelait tout à l'heure je crois
monsieur de virieu il s'est passé un
certain nombre de grands événements
notamment nous avons vu le mur de berlin
disparaître nous avons vu cette espèce
de séisme qui a ébranlé tous les pays de
l'europe de l'est et et pendant toute
cette période qui a été une période de
deux à la fois de tension d'excitation
extraordinaire il nous revenait à
l'esprit ce que le général de gaulle
avait dit au lendemain du coup de bragg
donc vous reprocher le chien doit être
la vision de réclamer aux élections que
patienter deux minutes lorsque je vais y
venir non je ne reproche pas à chirac de
ne pas être un visionnaire
je dis que lorsque tous ces événements
se sont produits nous souvenant de ce
que le général de gaulle lui-même avait
dit au lendemain du coup de prague à
savoir que ce qui venait de se passer
le confortait dans son dessein politique
et lui apporter la preuve que les
idéologies compris l'idéologie
communiste n'en porterai jamais sur les
nations et que parce que c'est qu'un
jour ou l'autre les nations européennes
se libère aurait pensé à ce que le
général de gaulle en quelque sorte avait
pressenti
nous avons souffert de voir que le rpr
était totalement absent personne n'a
rien dit alors il est bien évident que
le rpr c'est d'abord jacques chirac
on peut très bien le dire mais oui mais
mais vous mets toi blé lui aurait pu
parler et maintenant vous êtes rassurés
vous l'avez entendu dimanche vous pensez
que ce qu'il a proposé dans son grand
discours vous ne l'aviez pas entendu
récemment et qu'en tout cas c'est
suffisamment entraînant mobilisateur ça
nous verrons bien nous verrons je crois
en tous les cas que pour le moment le
débat qui devrait s'engager devant
l'afld devant les français et qui
conditionne l'avenir du pays à savoir
comment voit-on la place de la france en
europe
quelle doit être sa politique se débat
actuellement n'est pas engagé ou plus
exactement si il se déroule entre
monsieur de leurs partisans de
l'intégration et entre dessus me trompe
partisans de la confédération alors à
l'aube en où nous sommes absents du
débat
albert du roy reviendra sur ces
questions européennes au jour de la
nation que sur une passe décisive 1 pour
13 un produit quand je voudrais
simplement revenir sur vos propres
problèmes de stratégie politique
restons un petit peu dans l'hexagone
quand vous dites vous avez bien défini
le chant que vous vouliez couvrir sur le
sur l'échiquier politique et parmi ce
champ là il me semble avoir cru
comprendre qu'il y avait la clientèle de
l'extrême droite la clientèle du front
national ou d'aujourd'hui que vous
voulez que vous voudriez pas pouvoir
revenir vers vous prie pas
particulièrement je crois que d'abord
c'est pas la clientèle de l'extrême
droite
je crois que l'extrême droite en france
en tant que telle elle représente
toujours 2 à 3%
et puis il y à un état de vote
protestataire qui sont allés sur le
front national
d'abord parce que de 81 84 il n'y avait
pas d'autres réceptacle et les
communistes étaient au pouvoir la cgt
d'une courroie de transmission
gouvernement donc il n'y avait rien
d'autre
il n'avait pas venir sur nous puisque
nous avions été nous mêmes au pouvoir
jusqu'en 80
c'est ainsi que d'abord le front
national
s'est emparé d'une partie des dépôts et
du parti communiste ensuite il a il a
chassé sur nos terres parce que nous
avons effectivement cessé de dire un
certain nombre de choses qui nous
paraissait tellement évidente on n'en
parlait plus la patrie notre identité
culturelle etc
mais lui à employer ce terme ça a eu
tout un coup un air de nouveauté est
donc une partie de nos électeurs nous
ont lâchés comme dans le même temps et
ça c'était au lendemain de notre passage
au gouvernement comme dans le même temps
l'opposition était d'une mollesse
extraordinaire de s'exprimer sur rien
ces électeurs là que fut le cas
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui ce sont les
électeurs socialistes
je trouve que ces affiches dans les bacs
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis du front national
dont vous craignez comme beaucoup de
gens la poussée que faut-il faire
et si vous faire est ce qu'il faut faire
une alliance avec lui est ce qu'il faut
faire des accords de désistements entre
les deux tours ça des alliances comme
lui classé - là où est-ce qu'il faut
faire des accords de désistements
qu'est-ce qu'elle était secoué la veille
du front national ils l'ont la baraque
et résolument il faut d'abord dire aux
électeurs du front national qui sont des
français comme les autres et que nous
avons pour eux le respect la
considération qu'il mérite
il faut leur dire également que le pen
est l'alliée objective de mi temps et
qu'en réalité c'est à mi temps que tout
cela profite que chaque voix qui se
porte sur le front national comme
conséquence de diminuer l'impact de
l'opposition et c'est cela qu'il faut
dire et ce dans le même temps il faut
prendre position sur les problèmes voit
la main sur ces problèmes ce qu'il faut
reprendre les thèmes du front national
justement à votre compte ou et qu'elles
sont le dire autre chose et quels sont
les thèmes du front national mois contre
limoux l'intérieur c'est clair écoutez
j'ai été ministre de l'intérieur qui est
ce qui a fait reculer l'immigration
c'est le pen ou moi qu'est-ce qui a
lutté contre le terrorisme c'est lui ou
moi qui ait ce camion qui a fait qui a
fait régresser la délinquance
au contraire chaque fois il a été contre
nous certes mais dedans après vos deux
ans de gestion justement de gestion
chirac pasqua donc dans ce domaine
et il ne vous a pas échappé que jean
marie le pen a atteint son plus haut
score historique puisqu'il a fait 15% à
l'élection présidentielle est ce que
quand tu es bon 14 et demi point ses
portes absolument
mais est-ce que vous en avez tiré une
leçon de ce fait là au co font votre
politique n'a pas réussi à endiguer la
montée du front national probablement
parce que nous n'avons pas eu
suffisamment de temps et peut-être aussi
parce que nous n'avons pas été capable
de l'expliquer comme na ble ment ça a
été une de nos carences pas seulement
sur ce terrain mais sur beaucoup
d'autres mais il faut bien comprendre
une chose monsieur colombani
c'est pas moi je n'ai aucun complexe ni
vis-à-vis de l'extrême droite ni
vis-à-vis de la gauche
je veux dire par là que j'ai le
sentiment d'avoir fait plus ou moins
contre le racisme
par exemple que la gauche parce que
lorsque nous avons juguler l'immigration
clandestine juguler ce n'est jamais
vraiment possible
enfin nous y avons mis un terme à nos
frontières sont ouvertes vous savez
quand on tire l'était beaucoup moins
qu'aujourd'hui n'est pas bon pourquoi
c'est parce qu'on ne savons très bien
qu'à partir du moment où il ya une
immigration clandestine
les gens n'ayant pas de ressources le
processus qui se met en route
c'est l'assimilation entre étrangers
délinquants plus la xénophobie et le
racisme
donc les seules mesures qui ont été
prises à l'époque deux écuries qui ont
été prises depuis
les seules mesures pratiques efficaces
sur celle qu'a prise l'autre au
gouvernement mais dans le même temps
pour lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine
il ya d'autres mesures à prendre d'abord
nous n'aurions pas pu conduire la
politique que nous avons conduite
philippe seguin qui est derrière moi et
moi parce qu'il était ministre de la
population à cette époque là et une
partie de l'action le concerné la pauvre
l'action que nous avons conduite la
politique que nous avons conduite
ce sous l'impulsion de jacques chirac
c'est une politique commune de tout
gouvernement et notamment de nous deux
mais elle est simple si on veut moins
d'étrangers chez nous monsieur colombani
que faut-il faire
mais il faut faire en sorte qu'ils
trouvent du travail chez eux ce n'est
pas plus compliqué que cela c'est pas
plus compliqué mais c'est une affaire de
20 ou 30 ans où je vais vous le dire il
raison de plus il faut aider l'algérie
veut tellement ça prend 30 en raison de
plus pour commencer tout de suite
moi je n'aurais jamais pu obtenir le
résultat que j'ai obtenu à l'époque je
parle sur le contrôle de philippe qui
est derrière vous si nous n'avions pas
eu le concours de tous les pays
africains des pays maghrébins et cela je
ne l'oublient pas de même qu'il suffit
de regarder la place de la france sur
lui sur une carte pour se rendre compte
que dans son environnement immédiat le
maghreb est derrière ya l'afrique et il
est bien évident que notre intérêt
politique est aussi notre intérêt
économique les deux nous commande de
tout mettre en oeuvre pour aider à la
stabilité politique et au développement
économique de ces pays tout ce qui se
passe au maghreb aura fatalement des
conséquences chez nous à la fin du
siècle dans pas longtemps dans dix ans
il y aura 100 millions de maghrébins
dont 60% de moins de 20 ans et bien si
nous voulons
que les choses se passent comme la bleue
mans il faut aider l'algérie la tunisie
le maroc et il faut aider les pays
africains il nous sommes trop frileux et
je le regret de dire et je l'avais jeu
je le dis avec force j'ai le regret de
dix ans que la politique de coopération
que nous avons engagé avec jacques
chirac en direction des pays africains
des pays maghrébins a été en quelque
sorte abandonnées par le gouvernement de
gauche voilà la réalité des choses mary
jean marie comme le dit un dernier mot
qui est une petite inquiétude vous allez
nous dire si vous restez ou non
président du groupe sénatorial rpr parce
que cet après-midi avant le groupe vous
avez été critiqué on a même on vous a
même demandé de démissionner et vous
avez été critiqué par l'amiral de gaulle
je passe du poney le groupe et d'abord
les réunions d'abord c'est moi qui ait
provoqué cette réunion oui bon alors je
suis maso ou inconsciemment
alors pourquoi si vous jouez un choc
d'être critiqué par le fils de de gaulle
est pas du tout et pourquoi ne
critiquerai t-il pas moi je le critique
je vais d'ailleurs critiquer cet après
midi aussi bien j'ai pensé qu'il fallait
faire cette réunion dès aujourd'hui à
chaud pour que les gens s'expriment ils
se sont exprimés il ya eu un débat vif
et bien c'est très bien ainsi
et vous restez président vous partez
mais pourquoi je parte
c'est pas parce qu'il ya deux personnes
qui se disent pourquoi est-ce que vous
partez pas et pourquoi voulons que je
parte
jean marie colombani c'est vous qui
partez et on repasse
on repasse à svp geneviève moll mais
c'est parce que pensez-vous du non-lieu
pour monsieur l'outil n'en pense rien
les jeunes veulent vous avez droit à une
autre question avant c'est très bien
vous critiquez monsieur marché qui s'est
rendu c'est chaouchi ce coup mais vous
vous rendez souvent chez le roi du maroc
est ce qu'il n'ya pas là une petite
contradiction ça je dois dire que c'est
une question assez étonnante
d'abord je rappellerai simplement ceci
au cas votre votre correspondant
l'auraient oublié c'est que le maroc a
pris une part non négligeable la
libération de la france et que pas mal
de marocains sont tombés sur le sol
français
je rappelle aussi que le père du
souverain actuel une rock sa majesté
mohamed 5 était compagnon de la
libération
ce n'était pas le cas de monsieur
ceausescu bien on enchaîne avec albert
du roy pour un quart d'heure c'est parce
qu un homme ce droit tout d'abord
question rapide incisive et des réponses
courtes c'est ça
on se connaît alors ces conseils vous
pouvez répondre je pense brièvement à la
première question que je vous pose et
qu'est ce que c'est que cette espèce de
tricks que vous avez apporté qui était
fiché au mur ah c'est pas une trique ça
monsieur non non non je sais bien que
c'est pas une triple je veux savoir ce
que c'est un makila alors le bac il a
s'est tu te calmes qui est utilisé dans
le pays basque qui étaient utilisés
autrefois dans le pays basque par les
montagnards l'héberger mais j'aime bien
les bras ce que c'est un peuple de
montagnards une solide et ça me rappelle
que je suis moi-même de descendance de
montagnarde les jambes de feu également
rude et j'ai quelque chose aux communes
devaient avec eux quand j'étais enfant
j'ai été hébergée pendant les vacances
il ya quelque chose d'écrit aussi dessus
oui nous on ne voit pas d'ici c'est la
devise en basque ce assez combative dans
le combatif dans l'ombre et ensuite dans
la lumière
inflexible dans la lumière
je me suis fait traduire en effet c'est
bon je n'en ai pas parlé corse tout à
l'heure on ne parle pas basque
maintenant on ne l'ait pas fait une
démonstration ne voulait pas qu'on aille
vous la cherchez vous vous exposez
démontre non seulement
et si bercy est aussi une arme chargée
se déplacer comme disait dans les foires
etc
il revenait de l'argent où il est où ils
partent avec de l'argent il en fallait
une âme est donc cette can servir
d'armes il suffit de la davis et il ya
deux pointes redoutables
non je n'ai jamais servir un tract
terminé vous expliquer les valeurs que
vous vouliez que le rpr devienne un
grand parti central et non pas centriste
en dehors des cas social rassemblant le
peuple français dans les injures du roi
d'accord mais pardon oui je dans un
sondage qui était publié dans le figaro
par la sofres quelques jours avant les
assises il y avait une réponse qui
indiquait que la majorité des français
considéraient que le r
r favoriser plus les privilégiés que les
défavorisés tout à fait est ce que c'est
un filet le sondage n'avait été publié
qu'en partie est ce que c'est la vie qui
vous semblent fondées il y avait deux
chiffres le chiffre auquel vous faites
allusion de 7 45%
45% des français considéraient que nous
étions soutenus ont davantage les
classes privilégiées 2% et défavorisées
mais ça n'avait pas changé depuis 86 par
contre en 86 y en avait seulement 36%
fait ça donc ça s'est aggravé ces tags
rendez vous et vous êtes vous vous
partagez cette analyse à écouter ceux
qui compte 16 l'opinion des français
je crains malheureusement que nous ayons
peut donner cette impression
alors je croit notamment que pour nous
qui nous réclamons du gaullisme de ce
qu'il était c'est à dire représentatif
de l'ensemble de la nation française il
ya des choses qui sont ils ne sont pas
tolérables et dont nous devons nous
saisir
prenons maintenant des secteurs je
voulais je vais nous avons réussi
la politique de redressement économique
je crois qu'il doit réduire un conduit
une politique qui a donné et qui a
vraiment bien réussi
le résultat d'ailleurs nos successeurs
qui en profitent c'est la règle du jeu
tant mieux pour eux mais qu'est ce qu'on
constate on constate d'une part que les
entreprises n'ont jamais été aussi
prospères
on constate que créent des emplois
on constate que dans le même temps le
chômage ne diminue pas parce qu'il ya
toujours le même inadéquation entre
l'offre et la demande
c'est à dire un manque de formation une
inadaptation on constate dans le même
temps des profits boursiers important on
constate des opéras qui rapporte les
milliards vous avez dit dans votre
discours dimanche parce que je crois
très profondément
ça me choque ça m'interpelle et je me
dis qu'est ce qu'on fait pour les
salariés
est ce que les salariés reçoit la part
légitime qui devrait leur revenir des
fruits de l'expansion
la réponse est non est ce que les
socialistes font quelque chose pour la
réponse est non alors est ce que nous
allons décider à vous saisir de ce
problème les socialistes sont pas tous
tes fesses et à gauche les socialistes
ne sont plus socialistes qui sont
devenus des opportunistes alimentaire il
ya il ya un livre qui a fait pas mal
parler lui ces derniers ces derniers
jours qui s'appelle l'argent fou d'alain
minc et qui dit qui parle de l'arrogance
de l'argent et qui pronostique si elle
se poursuit une explosion sociale en
france est ce que c'est une crainte que
vous partagiez à moi ce que je crois
j'ai passion explosion sociale mais en
tous les cas ce que je vois je vois
notamment travers de mon département
ce que je vois c'est que si nous ne
faisons rien dans le 4 5 ans nous aurons
4 5 millions de pauvres dans ce pays
c'est une situation intolérable
inadmissible et l'arrogance de l'argent
c'est un terme que vous reprendriez
votre rôle en or grâce de l'argent elle
a toujours existé monsieur monsieur du
roi vous savez les gens qui ont vraiment
de l'argent depuis longtemps ne sont pas
heureux en ce qu'ils ont gagné
facilement et depuis peu de temps
en tendance est effectivement être
arrogant alors c'est ce qui l'aurait
mais six ans les affaires ce ne sont pas
un robin le fait par exemple que le les
revenus du capital soit considérablement
moins imposés que les revenus du travail
essentiellement les cd r c'est vrai choc
c'est pas normal c'est pas normal non
vous revenez au gouvernement est vrai
que c'est ce que nous avons fait vous
revenez au gouvernement est ce que vous
supprimer l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune pas d'abord je me serais
sûrement pas ministre des finances dans
le gouvernement mais votre gouvernement
à gouvernement d'abord je sais pas si
j'y serai bon enfin supposons que nous
soyons dans un gouvernement il le
propose vous le voter ou pas la
suppression de l'impôt sur la fortune
il entend départ dont la suppression de
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune
ah non je le voterai pas je le jeu
le mit associera pas c'est à dire que
vous souhaitez que ses impôts seront
maintenus oui crois qu'on a fait une
bêtise je vous rends la surprenait nous
avons cédé un peu trop facilement aux
sollicitations du patronat qui nous a
expliqué un certain nombre de choses
notamment la suppression de l'impôt sur
la fortune était indispensable pour
créer un climat de confiance et
deuxièmement que naturellement dès que
nous aurions aux affaires et que nous
aurions décidé de la suppression de
l'autorisation administrative de
licenciement
il se créerait automatiquement 300000
emplois eh bien il est évident que pour
gouverner un pays il faut pas tenir
compte des sollicitations des uns et des
autres nous avons cru qu'il fallait le
faire
je suis solidaire de ce qui a été fait
je ne nie pas je ne condamne personne je
me condamne moi même je dis que nous
avons eu tort il y aurait il y aurait
d'autres sujets lé mans sur le banc
philippe seguin mois quelques autres on
reconnaît qu'on a eu tort
il y en a qui reconnaissent pas qu'ils
ont eu tort nous on essaie de se
remettre en question on essaie de ceux
de se demander se poser un certain
nombre de questions il ya de le faire
sur le même thème il ya d'autres sujets
qu'on pourra aborder mais il faut palais
de l'europe puisque vous avez dit tout à
l'heure et vous avez raison évidemment
c'est essentiel mais en venant de dire
tout ce que vous venez de dire quand
même est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que vous êtes à contre courant de ceux
qui à droite
et quand même la mode dominante c'est à
dire le libéralisme soit sûr mais
complètement théval mais semblait
complètement égal je suis pas tellement
le je suis pour
pour la liberté en matière économique
parce qu'il est le véritable moteur de
l'économie la liberté mais je me
souviens aussi qu'en france nous sommes
dans une situation particulière en
france rien de grand ne s'est fait sans
l'état nous sommes pas les états unis
nous sommes pas l'angleterre
donc vous n'êtes pas la liberté mais
vous n'êtes pas tellement libéral si je
suis pour l'entreprise libre ça c'est
sûr mais je pense que l'état a un rôle à
jouer les grands investissements les
grands équipements personne ne les aurai
faire la place de l'état personnes on
reproche beaucoup à votre successeur de
vouloir recentraliser ses péchés d'un
jacobins il a jamais été et lui la gmv
centralisateur et vous avec ce que vous
venez d très bien moi avec ce que je
viens de dire je vais vous répondre je
suis actuellement président du conseil
général
lorsque j'étais ministre l'intérieur je
trouvais que la décentralisation était
une nécessité mais qu'elle était allée
un peu trop loin et c'est pas parce que
je suis président du conseil général
aujourd'hui que j'ai changé d'avis j'ai
toujours le même sentiment
et lorsque j'étais président du conseil
lorsque j'étais mise de l'intérieur
pendant excusez moi j'avais pris un
certain nombre de mesures comme mon
successeur d'ailleurs à continuer à
appliquer parce que la décentralisation
pour qu'elle fonctionne il faut qu'elle
marche sur ses deux pieds
je veux dire quand même temps qu on
décentralise il faut déconcentrer faut
que le président du conseil général est
un interlocuteur qui doit être le préfet
toutes les administrations de l'état
doivent être sous les ordres du préfet
sous sa compétence
ce n'est toujours pas le cas j'avais
commencé mais pour arriver à faire
entendre sa part un certain nombre
d'administrations centrales pour arriver
à ce qu'elles acceptent que leurs
directeurs départementaux sont sous les
ordres du préfet c'est pas aussi simple
avec faudra pourtant le faire quand on
vous entend redéfinir le rôle de l'état
on comprend pourquoi vous ne voulez pas
une fusion avec certains
libero que disons ultra du parti
républicain qui veulent la
décentralisation jean paul servais dur
du job le bon roman dans l'europe
l'europe
il ya une phrase qui m'a beaucoup frappé
dans votre discours aux assises de
dimanche vous y avez fait allusion tout
à l'heure en parlant du débat européen
entre la fédération de douleur et la
confédération de mitterrand vous avez
parlé de la lucidité de monsieur
mitterrand dans votre discours fois les
coutures absolument et dont je résume
votre formule elle était été dit
autrement qui en gros à récupérer l'idée
européenne du général de gaulle vous
êtes d'accord vous reconnaissez avez
vous ajouté der vous vous reconnaissez
dans la politique européenne de
mitterrand pour la langue pas si vite
alors passez vite parce que la politique
européenne limitant pour s'y reconnaître
il faudrait d'abord qu'il y en est une
et je ne la connais pas mais alors
pourquoi vous n'avez pas eu la lucidité
d'une seconde droit lorsque tous ces
événements d'europe de l'est ont éclaté
que s'est il passé notamment une très
grande silence de la part de la france
ont la france et pas seulement 55
millions d'habitants la france est le
pays des droits de l'homme c'est le pays
de la révolution c'est le pays de
l'autodétermination avec de gaulle
c'est une nation qui est présente sur
les cinq continents qui a une culture et
qui représente quelque chose pour tous
ces pays qui se libère
or au moment où le mur le berlin
s'effondre disparaît au moment où les
chaînes tombe
il se trouve que c'est le président de
la république française qui est
président du conseil européen et les
douze sont réunis à strasbourg
qu'est ce qu'on trouve à 10 ans ce soir
là seulement envers ces peuples qui se
libèrent
on leur dit la décision qui a été prise
c'est de créer une banque
je trouvais ça moi épouvantable fallait
dire j'imagine ce cours a dit le général
de gaulle peut-être même son corps d'amy
35 arabe alors si vous imaginez qu est
ce que je dis simplement que ces peuples
des besoins de chaleur
il avait besoin de sentir qu'ils étaient
accueillis on aurait dû leur temps dans
les bras on aurait dû leur dire on est
prêt à partager avec vous en faites vous
soignez vous êtes libre et dire on en
dirait qu'ils ont à dire à tous dès que
vous êtes démocratique
vous pouvez rentrer la communauté
européenne de la communauté européenne
elle est bien malade
il faut certainement une organisation de
l'europe c'est évident la communauté à
12 il a fait ses preuves est la fin
certains dans mon choses positives et
son temps est passé c'est fini
avec la réunification de l'allemagne
d'une part et tout ce qui se passe à
l'est
on imagine bien que ça ne sent plus
jamais l'europe sera jamais plus ce
qu'elle était si on continue dans
l'europe des 12 qu'est ce qu'on va faire
on va creuser un fossé à nouveau entre
les douze qui sont les nantis etc
et puis le reste de l'europe alors que
le mur vient de disparaître les flux il
faut au contraire leur temps dans les
bras alors j'ai donc été choqué et puis
au bout de quinze jours j'ai entendu
françois mitterrand dire parler de la
confédération des états européens
je me suis dit au moins voilà quelqu'un
qui a compris et que entre la petite
europe à 12 lors des nantis des frileux
etc
il faut proposer autre chose tu
réellement ce sera laurent m ce sera
très long
raison de plus pour le faire tout de
suite et alors là ce débat monsieur du
roi entre les partisans de l'intégration
et puis les partisans de la
confédération et ce débat se déroule
entre anti et qui entre deux socialistes
le dollar socialiste monsieur mitterrand
socialiste l'europe
leroyer pas qu'il faudrait qu'on se
mette un peu au milieu d'europe et c'est
à vous de le dire
l'europe à six étaient très faim plutôt
que de conciliabules et sur autre chose
là les différentes formations de
l'opposition le forez bien de se dire
parce que ça ça va conditionner la vie
des français et des jeunes générations
pendant 30 ou 40 ans selon l'évolution
qui aura lieu
il y aura des risques de tensions graves
voire merde de conflit en europe
l'europe à six étaient longues à faire
l'europe à neuf étaient encore que
difficile à faire le repas 12 déjà ya un
certain nombre d'européens qui disent
ils commencent à se dissoudre à net
recul aussi cohérente l'europe à 20
que vous envisagez est-ce que d'exister
encore et est ce que finalement la
raison pour laquelle vous souhaitez que
cette europe s'élargissent au maximum
c'est pas parce que vous n'êtes pas pour
l'intégration européenne
pourquoi nous prêtait d'aussi noirs
desseins messieurs du relais vous voulez
qu'elle se dissolve dans un ensemble
tellement vaste mais l'intégration
européenne de toute façon on est
irréalisable
chacun le sait il faut c'est monsieur il
faut être de l'or pour croire à ça à
lesparre il a la tête dans les nuages
la grande-bretagne n'acceptera jamais
l'intégration et vous pensez que
l'allemagne réunifiée ne va avoir qu'une
ambition c'est de servir de colonne
vertébrale à l'europe des 12 évidemment
pas l'unité monétaire monétaire faut
nettoyer à l'unité mon intervention
devait y arriver c'est très bien le
titre lui fait les allemands vont avoir
d'autres chats à fouetter un tueur
l'unité politique
lité politique mais écoutez on a eu tout
le temps de la faire l'unité politique
de gaulle lui-même l'avait proposé il ya
bientôt vingt ans plus de 20 ans et les
villas sauveur qu'il fallait essayer de
la mettre en existera jamais jamais ne
peut pas dire ça un exécutif européen
l'exécutif européen en tous les cas la
phrase on peut s'en remettre à personne
du soin d'assurer sa sécurité et
d'assumer sa politique étrangère ça
c'est tout à fait exclue est ce que si
on vous ayez un beau sujet de débat avec
monsieur giscard d'estaing par exemple
la dernière question l'intégration si on
vous l infini si l'on jettera être
question si on vous explique le terme le
qualificatif de nationalistes et ce que
voulait su mais ou pas si par
nationalistes aux entendez quelqu'un qui
aime sa patrie
je réponds oui je préférerais donc
patriotes nationalistes mais le
nationalisme tels que peuvent le
concevoir les français ça n'a rien à
voir avec ce sentiment peu d'arrogance
ne s'est pas du tout ça le la nation
française c'est pas ça c'est le
contraire ou de réflexion pas du tout
sur la rédation française c'est très
ouvert
c'est très accueillants et c'est porteur
d'un message vers l'extérieur c'est pas
leur plaît bien
on retourne
or les questions des téléspectateurs et
cp je ne vienne 3 dernière question 3
seulement
mais c'est pasqua est ce que vous ne
craignez pas cette réunification de
l'allemagne à laquelle nous assistons
je crois d'abord que la réunification de
l'allemagne est inévitable elle est en
route
je crois que c'est un sentiment normal
naturel pour le peuple allemand
peut-être aurait-il pu y avoir d'autres
évolutions et c'est vrai qu'il ya un an
ou deux on n'avait pas l'impression que
la réunification de l'allemagne et est
imminente
mais elle se réalise
à nous d'être vigilants et à nous aussi
actuellement de montrer aux allemands
que nous les comprenons
il s'agit pas de prendre une attitude
frileuse mais dans le même temps il faut
être vigilant notamment ce que disait ce
que nous disions tout à l'heure en
parlant de jacques delors
si nous réalisions l'intégration à
l'heure actuelle sur sur l'europe et le
monde il faut en être conscient
je veux me mais c'est parce qu'il ya une
question d'un représentant de commerce
qui se dit être udf pourquoi ne créez
vous pas votre propre parti politique
parce qu'il y en a déjà tellement que sa
forme de plus dans nos questions
question si vous aviez un choix à faire
entre monsieur mitterrand et monsieur le
pen qui choisiriez vous personne n'y
aura non on a commencé on a commencé par
la drogue je voulais terminer pas la
drogue
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec la
levée de tous secret bancaire dès qu'il
s'agit d'argent de la drogue
au menu j'avais moi même lorsque j'étais
ministre de l'intérieur demandé au
ministère des finances de mettre à notre
disposition une certaine nombre de
spécialistes pour pouvoir mettre un peu
d'entre eux nez dans ses affaires
mais la législation française être
très compliqué dans ce domaine mais
c'est vrai qu'il faut le faire juste un
dernier mot quand philippe seguin qui
est ici dit le gaullisme c'est une idée
neuve ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que si par goal is bond
dans le temps la primauté de l'intérêt
général sur les intérêts particuliers
si on entend le service de l'intérêt
général si on entend la solidarité si on
entend la générosité alors le gaullisme
c'est une idée neuve albert sur la
soulère guéret quoi vous leur direz vous
je ne signe jamais sauf d'échec de temps
en temps chez les commerçants vous
parlez de solidarité il ya d un grand
débat qui concerne la région parisienne
quand même 10 millions de personnes
vous êtes président du conseil général
des hauts-de-seine l'europe a échappé
oui non les hauts-de-seine s'est
considéré comme un département
privilégié dans la région parisienne et
puis il est question de faire partager
un peu entre les départements ou les
comme une des plus riches et les
départements les communes l'aja
parisiennes les plus pauvres est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ce partage
d'abord comme disait l'autre ont chacun
ses pauvres je veux dire par là que les
hauts de seine c'est pas quelque chose
où la richesse est uniformément répartie
il y en a apparemment moins qu'en
seine-saint-denis
écoutez il ya malakoff à bagneux il ya
un certain nombre de secteurs
à gennevilliers un certain nombre de
secteurs difficiles nommé la solidarité
c'est une solidarité au niveau d'une
régie solidarité mais nous ne la faisons
déjà au niveau du département nous la
pauvreté
on est de droite mais ça veut pas dire
que les votes coeur comme on dit
quelqu'un quand monsieur rocard découvre
tout d'un coup la nécessité de rénover
les hlm
je sais pas évidemment il doit pas
connaître beaucoup d'achats la mena
n'ayant pas vu beaucoup dans sa vie et
lui bon compte tenu de ses origines mais
nous ce qui nous concerne lorsque
monsieur roch envers mes 20 millions
pour rénover les hlm nous en mettons
deux sens dans notre département nous
tombe 200 millions cette année pour
honorer les offices hlm
lorsque dans le cadre de la lutte contre
la pauvreté la précarité le gouvernement
mais un million nous en mettons 10 est
ce que je demandais aux assistantes
sociales le monde département on leur a
donné les moyens pour qu'elles ne
répondent pas à une demande de quelqu'un
qui est malheureux par l'imprimé on leur
en donne les moyens pour qu'elle réglait
les problèmes sur place alors monsieur
rocard et son gouvernement
plutôt que de nous donner des leçons des
conseils il ferait mieux d'assumer leurs
responsabilités bien leurs
responsabilités ils ne les assume pas
dans le domaine de la construction
logement des transports
alors nous n'avons aucun complexe la
solidarité oui mais que le gouvernement
donne l'exemple
ilan est loin bien mais c'est pasqua
comme monsieur dollars le mois dernier
vous à l'échappée offert dicte la sofres
parce que en effet le nouvel horaire de
l'émission fait que la sofres ne peut
plus faire ces sondages dans des
conditions de rigueur scientifique
suffisante et que nous avons préféré y
renoncer
voilà alors vous allez maintenant signer
avec nous le livre d'or c'était l'heure
de vérité de monsieur charles pasqua
prochain rendez vous le mercredi
le mardi 13 mars invités monsieur
raymond barre pour soir
[Musique]